Oui c'est le jour de Noël.
Mais hier,
je ne sais pas pourquoi, dans la vidéo j'avais qu'il y aurait une grosse annonce aujourd'hui...
enfin pas une annonce, mais...
quelque chose d'un peu ouf...
Et c'est le cas ! Evidemment !
Bonjour et bienvenue pour la dernière vidéo du mois de décembre,
et de la dernière vidéo du calendrier de l'Avent.
Parce que ce soir c'est Noël, c'est les cadeaux, c'est l'amour, c'est la famille,
c'est ce que tu veux.
Enfin, ne fais pas l'amour à ta famille d'ailleurs, ça n'aurait aucun sens...!
Mais par contre, je me suis demandé comment j'allais finir cette vidéo.
Enfin cette série de vidéos, je vais vous le dire,
c'est la dernière de décembre,
là il n'y en aura plus, je prends quelques jours de repos.
Et l'année prochaine, sur la chaine,
il va encore se passer d'autres choses.
Je sais, on dit tous ça, tout le monde, tous les youtubers ont dit ça,
mais je crois que j'ai vraiment besoin de ces quelques jours de recul sur YouTube,
pour revoir un petit peu ce que j'ai envie de faire, comment j'ai envie de faire,
je me suis un peu laissé prendre par le rythme avec tous les projets que j'avais cette année et tout ça,
c'était vraiement cool, mais j'ai envie de retrouver encore plus de plaisir et de passion sur la chaine,
donc je ne sais pas quelle forme ça va prendre.
Ça ne va pas changer grand chose pour vous, en terme de sortie de vidéo et tout ça...
Mais moi ça va me faire du bien en fait quelques jours à réfléchir sur ce que je fais sur YouTube.
Là, pour terminer cette vidéo, durant presque 1 mois, durant 24 jours,
je vous ai présenté tout ce qui fait parti de mon univers dans ce que je peux kiffer comme jeux, comme livres, etc.
Je pense, je pressens qu'il y en a qui vont penser que ce sont des placements de produits, mais il n'y en avait pas un seul sur la chaine,
sur ces 24 vidéos.
Voilà, je le dis, je le répète, quand il y en a un je vous le dis.
Et je ne vous le dis pas souvent, parce que j'en fais très peu.
Voilà, c'est aussi simple que ça !
Et donc ces idées là, c'était peut être des idées de cadeaux, soit à faire à vos proches, soit à recevoir.
Et je suis persuadé, qu'il y n a qui ont demandé des trucs que j'ai présenté comme cadeaux à Noel.
Donc quel est le propos de cette vidéo ?
C'est que je vais vous donner l'opportunité de gagner pleins de choses parmi celles que j'ai présenté.
Alors, pas les miens parce que je ne vais pas vous offrir des trucs d'occasion et qui m'appartiennent. Je n'ai pas envie de les donner.
Par contre je vais vous les racheter, moi même, avec mes petits deniers pour vous les offrir.
Je vais vous offrir 10 choses, qu'il y avait dans ce calendrier de l'Avent.
10 objets, livres, jeux...
Et c'est vous qui allez choisir quoi.
Et l'interêt de faire ça, c'est-à-dire que Noël va passer,
avant le tirage au sort,
une fois que le tirage au sort sera passé, vous allez pouvoir aussi composer parmi tout ce que vous avez vu sur la chaine,
sur tout ce que vous voulez, en excluant les choses que vous avez déjà, ça vous évitera d'avoir des doublons
c'est un peu l'idée de ce concours.
Et la seule chose qui n'entre pas en jeu dans ce concours, c'est Cozmo.
Puisque dans la vidéo 17 je vous avez présenté ce petit robot,
qui était déjà gagné, et je fais le tirage au sort après demain, le 26.
C'est la vidéo 17, vous l'avez en lien juste ici, là. Je vous la mets par là haut.
Donc ce sera à choisir parmi toutes les autres choses.
Est-ce que c'est bien clair ?
Dans l'idée, ce concours, si vous le gagnez, vous créez un panier virtuel et vous me dites: "Dedans Fabien, tu me mets ça, ça, ça, ça, ça, ça, ça..."
10 choses ni plus, ni moins,
et je vous achète ça, et je vous envoie ça par la poste.
Je vais mettre un tweet en place dès aujourd'hui,
vous allez donc le trouver donc sur Twitter, ça me paraît évident...
et pour participer à ça,
il faut me dire dans le tweet, le jeu qui vous ferais le plus plaisir,
retweeter ce tweet,
et suivre mon Twitter.
Je fais le tirage au sort le 3 janvier,
et si on passe d'ici le 3 janvier, la barre des 10 000 RT du tweet
je ferais gagner 2 personne, donc il y aura deux personnes qui pourront se faire un petit panier, comme ça...
avec 10 objets.
J'espère que cette idée de cadeaux vous plaira.
C'est mon côté Père Noel ! [voix du Père Noel]
J'espère que vous avez été sages cette année ! [voix Père Noel]
Abonne toi !
Like !
Et dépêchez vous les petits schroumpfs ! [voix du grand schroumpf]
Ciao !
A l'année prochaine !
Bye bye ! Je vous kiffe !
Merci pour cette année de malade !
[musique]